und das waren ganz schöner schock für
uns seit wir letztens erfahren haben
dass wir ausziehen müssen und zwar so
bald wie möglich wir haben sechs siegen
wir haben acht hühner und einen riesen
garten ein großes gewächshaus und jede
menge kram der damit zusammenhängt und
damit einfach mal so mal eben umzuziehen
ist eine richtig große nummer unsere
vermieter haben uns letztens
angesprochen und gesagt dass die
eigenbedarf anmelden und unsere wohnung
für ihre kinderzimmer brauchen also die
haben vier kinder und nur zwei zimmer
wir wussten das gar nicht weil die so
ein riesenhaus teil da drüben haben und
jetzt von außen immer so rosig aussieht
aber anscheinend haben die da richtig
platzmangel und jetzt müssen wir
ausziehen und zwar ganz ganz schnell und
es ist total heftig für uns auch also
ich verstehe dass die vermieter probleme
haben und so und bin deswegen auch nicht
böse ist und nicht dass das jemand
versteht es ist für uns als sehr sehr
heftig dass wir so schnell jetzt einfach
neues zuhause suchen müssen wir sind
sowieso schon seit jahren auf der suche
nach einem haus oder hof dass wir kaufen
wollen mit viel platz für alle unsere
projekte
und dass jetzt innerhalb von drei
monaten hinzukriegen ist eigentlich
unmöglich und ich bin an so einem punkt
angelangt wo ich nicht mehr unbedingt in
eine mietwohnung ziehen möchte wo wir
dann ein bis zwei jahre bleiben wieder
den riesen garten anlegen wieder
irgendwie orte für unsere ganzen tiere
suchen müssen und das gewächshaus kann
man auch nur einmal auf und abbauen also
nehmen kann es ist jetzt einmal
aufgebaut und wir könnten es noch einmal
abbauen und dann nochmal einmal irgendwo
anders aufbauen aber wir können das
nicht alle zwei jahren uns umziehen und
ja wir haben schon länger eine
unglaubliche sehnsucht danach ein
eigenes grundstück zu haben wo wir
richtig was rein stecken können wo wir
bäume pflanzen klein besetzte zone für
unsere tiere bauen können so dass sie
sich nicht mehr in elektrozäune
strangulieren und wir eigentlich jedes
jahr eine tote ziege im zaun hängen
haben und wo sie einen festen stall
bauen können und einfach mal so richtig
ankommen wo man sich auch richtig mit
dem boden verbinden kann ich verbinde
mich auch so immer mit allen werten die
wir bei gärtnern aber es ist es tut
einfach weh wenn man das dann wieder
hinter sich lassen muss und das haben
wir jetzt so oft hinter uns dass wir
wirklich auf der suche sind nach was
festnehmen und das ist jetzt ganz akut
für uns geworden und da wollte ich euch
ein bisschen darüber erzählen was da
gerade so bei uns los ist und euch ein
bisschen mitnehmen auch auf diese reise
zu unserem hof ihr werdet das irgendwie
mitbekommen hier auf dem kanal das will
dann irgendwo ankommen und landen werden
und ich hoffe hoffe ein ort ist wo wir
dann auch bleiben können ja darum geht
es in diesem video es ist also ein
bisschen ein anderes video als sonst
aber ich hoffe dass es euch trotzdem
freude macht dann diese reise
mitzuerleben die wir jetzt in den
nächsten monaten und jahren vor uns
haben ja wir haben hier eigentlich so
viel glück wir sind mitten in der stadt
das merkt man immer gar nicht in den
videos oder wir haben eine super schöne
wohnung die ist zwar sehr klein ist und
eine 60 quadratmeter für drei leute aber
das reicht irgendwie aus unser
wohnzimmer ist eine halbe scheune es ist
nicht teuer auch wenn es immer so schick
aussieht ich lese auch immer so
kommentare ja marie ist voll die gutshof
dame und so weiter
nein es ist nicht teuer hier zu tun es
ist super gemütlich und schön und wir
verstehen uns super gut mit den nachbarn
und den kindern die hier immer im darum
setzen wir haben ganz viel platz die
kinder haben ein baumhaus eine schaukel
eine seilbahn mitten im garten es ja es
ist eigentlich der perfekte ort für uns
gewesen
außerdem hat jetzt müssen
also wären irgendwer da draußen ein von
einem haus mit großem garten also sagen
wir mal ja so 4000 quadratmeter sollte
schon sein eher richtung zwei bis drei
hektar
kennt das irgendwo in der gegend kassel
göttingen ist und gut angebunden ist das
heißt wir müssen entweder nach kassel
oder nach wertingen jeden morgen mit
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln gut
hinkommen das ist ganz ganz wichtig dann
schreib mir gerne eine e-mail wird mich
super freuen wenn da irgendwie finden
sich da irgendwas ergeben könnte ich bin
euch nochmal die e mail adresse hier ein
werdet mit bekommen wie wir einen
kompletten selbstversorger hof neu
aufbauen und anlegen und ich glaube dass
das für ganz viele da draußen sicher
sehr interessant werden kann was uns da
noch bevorsteht für uns ist es gerade
sehr schrecklich aber eigentlich ist es
vielleicht auch der tritt in den hintern
den wir gebraucht haben um wirklich
ernsthaft mit
vollgas nach dem richtigen hof zu suchen
weil wir haben es hier eben total schön
die haben es war immer geschaut nach
häusern und grundstücken und so weiter
und wir haben jede woche die
immobilienportale angeschaut und uns
immer mal wieder sachen angeschaut die
dann aber leider nicht gepasst haben
aber wir haben das eben nicht so
intensiv betrieben wie wir das jetzt
machen müssen weil wir dazu gezwungen
sind also vielleicht
ergibt sich daraus ja was ganz tolles im
moment fühlt es sich einfach nur
schrecklich an und es wird sich kraft
ein wenn man ein zuhause hat und
sich so mit einem ort verbunden fühlt da
schon so viel zeit und arbeit
reingesteckt hat sich das so
einzurichten dieses gewächs zu bauen
dass wir vor einem jahr aufgebaut haben
und jetzt wieder abbauen müssen es ist
einfach super super ärgerlich aber ich
glaube irgendwie dass sich daraus was
positives entwickeln könnte ich hoffe
ist und ich erzähle ich mal ein bisschen
was wir unsere probleme sind also es
sind sehr privat normal als hätte ich
gar nicht so persönliche sachen hier auf
dem kanal
ja mein freund ist nicht so der
selbstversorger typ der hält sich da
eigentlich ziemlich raus also hilft mir
schon ganz viel und ich bin auch sehr
dankbar dafür dass er das macht aber es
ist nicht seine leidenschaft das ist
alles kommt eigentlich alles von mir
weiß nicht ob es euch vielleicht auch so
geht das ich vielleicht ein partner habt
der da eigentlich gar nicht so
begeistert von ist und dann ist es
natürlich umso schwerer was zu finden
weil er es auf dem land aufgewachsen und
hat eigentlich lust jetzt mal so ein
bisschen das stadtleben kennenzulernen
und das hatten wir jetzt hier auch das
natürlich eine kleine stadt aber das
hatten wir hier sehr schön man kann hier
einfach ins café laufen oder auf dem
marktplatz das ist ein bisschen unter
spannung ist fällt gerade weil ich ganz
viel platz haben will und ich mag es
auch gut angebunden zu sein jetzt das
nur nicht ganz so wichtig wie ihm aber
da müssen wir eben auf alle bedürfnisse
achten die wir haben und gut angebunden
sein und richtig viel platz haben lässt
sich irgendwie total schwer vereinen was
ist was alle suchen also was wir uns
perfekt wäre wäre ein kleiner hof mit
genug platz für ein paar tiere ich hätte
auch so gerne kühe ihr könnt euch das
gar nicht vorstellen ich werde seit
jahren von kühn und eigentlich hatte ich
meinen freund auch soweit das sind mehr
erlaubt hat in anführungszeichen man
muss das ja schon immer absprechen ja
wahrscheinlich ist das utopisch aber
vielleicht ist das ja auch gerade der
moment da ja dass ich kurz davor wenn
meine ganzen wilden selbstversorger
träume die hier und hier alle noch
schlimmer dass wir die umsetzen können
ich hätte solisten lehmofen zu bauen
draußen küche und kühl zu halten und
gehen ich will gehen will sollte also
vielleicht ist das jetzt genau der
moment den wir gebraucht haben dass wir
dort finden der den wir dann richtig zu
hause sein können und zwar langfristig
und an dem wir ein richtig richtig
tollen hof aufbauen können das wird also
auf jeden fall auch wegen ihr könnt mir
gerne mal unten in die kommentare
schreiben
ob ihr auch so große träume in euch habt
und was euch dann noch zurückhält und wo
eure selbstversorger reise hingehen soll
ich freue mich auf jeden fall euch auf
unsere mitzunehmen und werde euch auf
dem laufenden halten wie sich das ganze
so entwickeln würde macht's gut und bis
nächste woche cheese
[Musik]